alors les jeunes ça va on va c'est
gentil devenu voir pp pour son
anniversaire
et oui j'ai 99 ans et je pète le feu
jean mois 50 ans devant moi et j'ai
décidé d'en profiter parce que je viens
de m'apercevoir qu'en 99 ans j'ai perdu
tout mon temps j'ai rien qu'en dormant
huit heures par jour j'ai calculé que
dans ma vie j'ai roupiller pendant 33
ans
en plus j'ai perdu au moins six mois de
ma vie et c'est devait redémarrer ma
voiture
les pousser pendant au moins un an et
demi les ai mis deux ans pour la
revendre rien qu'au petit déjeuner dans
ma vie j'ai calculé que je me suis tapé
700000 tartines de pain avec deux tonnes
de beurre en 99 ans seulement trois
paquets de cigarettes par jour j'ai
calculé que gm allait 800 kg de nicotine
et trois tonnes de goudron de coire
boudronnée l'autoroute paris marseille
des doors et oui incroyable
rien qu'en regardant la télé mission
trois heures tous les jours j'ai calculé
que dans ma vie je suis resté 12 ans
devant la télé 12 ans assis le cul dans
un fauteuil à tripoter les boutons
dans six mois entier passer devant le
panneau veuillez nous excuser de ce
merdier momentanée incroyable tant qu'on
peut perdre avec ces petites conneries
un rien de temps faire pipi c'est rien
du tout cinq minutes tous les jours et
bien 90 me venger guette kulik j'ai
pissé pendant un oeil mais un an et demi
enfermés dans les toilettes
même en prison ils sont mus en plus
d'air je tenais pas le temps que j'ai
perdu à faire des petits câlins d'amour
avec ma mémé nador et un petit câlin par
ci un petit câlin par là en 99 ans je me
suis tapé 92 miller de taille à sous et
franchement je me sens encore bien petit
quart d'heure supplémentaire